(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] You're in Budapest.
And you feel like having a drink.
There's vodka, gin, rum, lemonade,
but this would all be a mistake.
Because in this city, you have to indulge
in a glassful of Hungarian history.
Well, actually, three to be exact.
Meet Pálinka, Unicum and soda water.
Mm.
Without further ado, let's
bring in our experts.
First up, Zoltan who heads up
the House of Hungarian
Pálinka in Budapest.
- Pálinka is a strong spirit.
It is 100 percent fruit distilled.
Pálinka is deeply woven into
the fabric of Hungarian society.
Everybody knows what it is.
And the history of Pálinka began in 1300s
when the Queen and the King of Hungary
were all suffering from gout.
They stumbled upon this
earlier version of Pálinka,
which they used to cure themselves.
It is made from a huge variety of fruits,
apricots to plums to
cherries to pears to apples.
- [Narrator] Now we've
heard it's quite strong.
- The usual alcohol content is typically
between 40 and 50 percent, some of them 60 percent.
Some of them even higher.
- [Narrator] Can your
Unicum beat that, Sándor?
- We can't beat it, but we can match it
because we also have 40 percent.
Really, Unicum is a bitter herbal liquor;
there's roughly 10 million Hungarians,
and we sell yearly 4 million bottles.
It was invented in 1790 by my ancestor.
I am the sixth generation.
- [Narrator] See this
doctor was the physician
to the Emperor of Austria-Hungary.
And when the Emperor had a bad stomach.
- My ancestor made him Unicum,
which is made of 40 different
kinds of herbs and spices.
The recipe's a secret,
so I can tell you that,
for example, we use vanilla or ginger.
OK, I told you two.
That's enough.
(laughs)
- [Narrator] And for you
non-drinkers, there's soda water.
A staple on Hungarian tables.
This is László and his father.
(speaking foreign language)
- [Narrator] Thank you, gentlemen.
No wonder László knows his stuff.
It was in Hungary where
the large scale production
of soda water started.
(speaking in foreign language)
Shall we taste them?
Bottom's up, gents.
- That was strong.
- That's a good drink.
- That was great.